direction le vivat ville à 70 kilomètres
de la pologne à l'ouest de l'ukraine
point de passage pour les ukrainiens
leurs priorités quitter le pays un
couvre-feu a été instauré de 22 heures à
6 heures du matin où l'on retrouve tout
de suite notre envoyé spécial tarek
kayes vous êtes en ukraine vous avez
traversé la frontière polonaise la nuit
dernière qu'avez vous constaté
tout à fait nous avons effectué cette
traversée hier soir où nous nous sommes
rendus d'objets mais jusqu'à ils vivent
comme vous l'avez dit lviv qui se trouve
à 70 km de la frontière polonaise et
principale ville où capitale culturelle
de l'ukraine ce trajet que nous avons
effectués et le trajet est exactement
inverse qu effectuent tous ceux qui
fuient l'ukraine tous ceux qui fuient la
guerre essentiellement des régions de
l'est du nord où de manière générale de
l'ukraine de manière générale ils fuient
tous donc l'ukraine pour se rendre en
pologne et dans d'autres pays européens
ce que nous avons vu c'est que les
postes frontières sont toujours le
théâtre d'un flux incessant de ces
réfugiés les trains qui arrivent ou qui
partent de d'ukraine sont bondés au bord
de ses trains il s'agit essentiellement
de femmes et d'enfants et d'enfants en
bas âge également de personnes âgées
puisque les hommes qui ont entre 18 et
60 ans sont interdits de sortie
d'ukraine mais ce que nous avons vu
également c'est le passage d'ukrainiens
de l'autre côté de la frontière de
pologne jusqu'en ukraine il s'agit
essentiellement de deux ukrainiens de la
diaspora qui participent ou qui
souhaitent participer à leur manière à
cet effort de guerre ce sont des sommes
en capacité de combattre mais il ya
également beaucoup de femmes j'en ai
rencontré plusieurs noms olga par
exemple qui traversera le pays d'ouest
en est ce pour se rendre auprès de ses
parents puisque elle disait qu'elle
pouvait pas ne pas être à leurs côtés
dans ces tragiques et quelle est la
situation dans la ville de lives
la situation à lviv est plutôt calme
mais une tension très pin pad et
présente cette ville donc comme je le
disais où affluent un très grand nombre
de réfugiés et de déplacés la tension
était palpable les militaires et les
policiers se trouvent en très grand
nombre dans la ville rien que depuis ce
matin on nous a demandé à plusieurs
reprises de présenter nos pièces
d'identité les autorités locales cani la
présence d'agents russes infiltrés qui
serait en capacité de commettre des
actes de sabotage de couvre-feu comme
vous l'avez dit a été imposé entre 22
heures et 6 heures du matin dès la
tombée de la nuit la ville se transforme
en une ville fantôme
recommande même aux habitants d'éteindre
les lumières chez eux à partir de 23
heures des écoles et les universités ont
également été fermés de même que les
musées comme je le disais les vives
c'est la capitale culturelle d'ukraine
avec la présence de dizaines de musées
de théâtre d'opéra toute cette ville
culturelle a été figé depuis le début du
conflit certains théâtres ont même été
transformé en un lieu d'hébergement un
centre d'accueil des réfugiés ce que
vous voyez derrière moi probablement
c'est la statue de neptune et c'est un
des monuments de cette ville donc les
statuts et des monuments beaucoup de ses
statuts et des monuments figure sur la
liste du patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
cette statue là comme beaucoup d'autres
statuts est enrobé de matériel qui la
protégerait de d'éventuelles frappes
russe donc pour résumer situation plutôt
calme mais très tendu où on commence à
se préparer à des à des joueurs beaucoup
plus difficile ici à vie merci beaucoup
tarek cas et pour toutes vos précisions